hold on wait wait wait for all the
[ __ ] anars at these labels [ __ ]
shout them out man
what a fake shout out to my bae mona leo
name
she [ __ ] she she inspired me to
do this
but anyways back to
you know what i mean
if you're artists at these labels bro
this sound that you're hearing coming
out of michigan bro
it's a flint song okay it's from flint
pay attention to flint
we got rio de jungo g
who free him
from
we got ysr grams we got
grind hard e
we got [ __ ] crispy life kid
we got king cashes for the record crispy
life kid is is a
that's an amazing name
we got we got wireshark grams
[ __ ] we got [ __ ] we got we got
we got we got jeff skye
jeff scott's the [ __ ] kendrick
lamar [ __ ] shout out to flint
go scoop these [ __ ] these [ __ ] go
[ __ ] these [ __ ] gonna sell king
cashes
i'm trying to tell you if you're an r at
these labels bro go grab some flint kids
do it
i'm trying to tell you do i got to say
the names again
louie ray grinehar e
crispy life kid king cashes
ysr grams
flint
darrell rich
flint
please go no no i got the real rich
don't worry about him you already i
ain't got him on paper yet but i ain't
worried about dang about to go grab
nobody out of flint anyway they gonna
wait till [ __ ] pop anyway um jeff
skies that's how it works man that's the
kendrick lamar flint oh watch that [ __ ]
video i'm trying to tell you [ __ ]
y'all gonna wait till these [ __ ] pop
and they're gonna be like damn i heard
pac-man said in the interview he said it
first
y'all gonna wait to these y'all [ __ ]
gonna wait till these [ __ ] get a hit
record man y'all gonna wait till these
[ __ ] catch a little buzz y'all gonna
wait till they get a hundred thousand
followers on instagram then they gonna
call they gonna call and i'm gonna be
right there like hey
make them [ __ ] get you a 50 50 split
no distribution fee
i'm be giving them [ __ ] all the game
that i had to learn [ __ ]
well make them make them get you
i don't even know the name of it i don't
even know what's the proper language for
it but let them hold the masters for
like 10 years or five years and then
they return back to you um
i'm gonna be giving them [ __ ] the
sauce [ __ ] cause y'all [ __ ] don't
wanna go pick them up right now i'm
telling y'all well look man the album is
out flint michigan [ __ ] i'm trying to
tell you